bien écouter l'information bien sûr a
circulé ici à mignovillard dès la fin de
l'après-midi les habitants ont entendu
la nouvelle des aveux de nordahl le
landais des habitants qui se sont
montrés très discrets mais surtout très
respectueux de la douleur et de
l'intimité de la famille de miley c'est
une règle qui se sont donnés depuis six
mois déjà
alors certains que nous avons croisé
avec qui nous avons pu échanger et bien
on dit le choc que cela représente
les habitants ici ont toujours retenu
une ligne d'espoir par droiture et aussi
en soutien à la famille de maylis mais
ils disent aujourd'hui le choc
la sidération et certains ont osé ce mot
difficile au fil de la discussion le mot
de soulagement connaître enfin la vérité
sur maylis alors au moment où je vous
parle les gendarmes se sont positionnés
dans le hameau ici près de mignovillard
est tout près de la maison des parents
de maylis pour tenir à distance les
journalistes
et d'éventuels curieux mais il faut bien
dire ici c'est le silence qui prime
une sorte d' immobilisme un moment
difficile dans la tente de nouvelles
plus précises